[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue c'est la dernière édition de la
semaine est peut-être la meilleure ça
dépend de nos quatre invités mais ils
sont au taquet pour nous parler des
quatre sujets que nous avons sélectionné
aujourd'hui nous reviendrons sur le
passage de jean luc mélenchon hier dans
l'émission politique le leader de la
france insoumise a encore gravi un
palier dans la pugnacité ou
l'agressivité faut-il s'en réjouir ou
s'en inquiéter
nous en parlerons nous parlerons aussi
d'une étude publiée ce matin dans le
figaro et que l'endroit au pew research
center qui est un think tank américain
cette étude nous dit que en 2050 il y
aurait entre 17 et 18% de français qui
seraient musulmans contre 8 pour cent et
quelques aujourd'hui quel est l'impact
d'une telle d'une telle mesure est que
la classe politique en prend
véritablement conscience nous en
parlerons nous parlerons aussi des
électeurs de droite à l'occasion d'un
sondage publié ce week-end dans le
figaro magazine
les électeurs de droite sont ils
contradictoires d'un côté dans leurs
attentes
il montre clairement leur positionnement
sur des sujets régaliens et en même
temps comme on dit à l'elysée il verrait
d'enlacer bonneuil des listes communes
entre les républicains et la république
en marche et puis nous parlerons des
bitcoins nous allons vous expliquer
comment faire fortune facilement ne
zappez pas non nous allons expliquer de
comprendre ce qui se passe avec cette
monnaie virtuelle dont la valeur s'est
envolé est ce dangereux est ce
inquiétant est ce une nouvelle bulle
nous allons en parler avec nos quatre
invités bonsoir merci bayard
enfin vous êtes rédacteur en chef au
service économie entreprises du figaro
les célèbres pages saumon à vos côtés
laurent bouvet politologue universitaire
essayiste vous enseignez à sciences po
saint germain en laye et vont persister
de versailles sens versailles saint
quentin en yvelines à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
faisait bon se poser mes fiches ne sont
pas à jour
merci de l'avoir corrigé mais vous êtes
bien l'auteur de la gauche zombies voilà
chronique d'une malédiction politique
bon là cette fois ci j'ai de bons enfin
bon soir benjamin grange pour soi vous
êtes président de dentsu consulting
votre spécialité c'est la communication
numérique les stratégies d' influence en
particulier sur internet et hervé nathan
nous a aussi rejoint bonsoir hervé
vous êtes directeur adjoint de la
rédaction de marianne et votre
hebdomadaire publie cette semaine un
dossier de couverture sur les nouveaux
censeurs je vous propose de commencer
par revenir sur la prestation remarquée
de jean luc mélenchon chez nos confrères
de france 2 hier avec un ton qui était
clairement offensive voire un peu plus
au cas où vous auriez raté l'épisode
précédent en voici le meilleur je
déteste cette société madame salamé jeu
et ses valeurs sa cupidité la lutte de
tout le monde contre chacun la dureté et
la cruauté à l'égard des autres ça y est
vous avez fini il y en a un qui veut en
rajouter encore dans cinq minutes vous
êtes tous les deux par terre merkel elle
aussi elle a fait la maligne elle a tous
serrés eva bravo les excès dans la
mentalité de rentiers jose sharks ou que
l'on perde son temps à discuter du
venezuela dans une grande émission
nationale avec quelqu'un dont c'est sans
doute l'heure de gloire que d'être venue
réciter ici les éléments de langage quoi
de l'opposition ces méprises j'en ai
marre dessus oui c'est méprisant prison
elle garde oui madame
j'en ai par dessus la tête de genre de
numéro chaque fois que je vais quelque
part je me tape venezuela on va faire
une boîte vous savez comme les vaches
qui font mieux là mais de là à vous me
sortez pour tous qu'elle l'a tant que
celle là
lebel l'égard d'autres contrats gav
appartient à mort et une fusion et non
un mot de conclusion voulu tourner le
dos là non non je range mes papiers
voilà bien sûr elle ne trouve pas les
déclarations des autres pour coup avec
sa mère ok alors quand vous considérez
par exemple là où de toute façon si la
salle est comme ça quand vous considérez
quelquefois à dure un bon tampon fait
pas ce qu'on veut jamais trouvé dans son
vin est retenu il avait toujours été à
mon égard j'ai toujours été moquée je
vous connais on se connaît depuis
longtemps on apprend t on à la nuit des
noirs est encore une intervention plus
au ps alors qu'en même temps des biens
mais arrêté de dire c'est que c'était
journée le droit merci à charles darche
qui a monté les meilleurs extraits de
l'émission laurent bouvet on est encore
dans le débat politique là parce qu'en
fait on discute plus avec l'autre où
l'on le disqualifie ça tient plus du
combat de boxe que d'une émission
classique de politique
oui ce qui m'a frappé j'ai regardé
l'émission hier en direct ce qui m'a
frappé c'est c
je me suis demandée en fait est-ce qu'il
joue est ce que c'est une mise en scène
il avait un peu théorisé le bruit et la
fureur vous vous souvenez c'était son
expression quand il s'en prenait
notamment dans la campagne de 2012 aux
journalistes de manière assez assez
vivant il avait été n'avait été très dur
c'était comme une stratégie et je me
suis demandé si hier soir il revenait à
cette stratégie éventuellement pour
quelle raison on pourrait en dire un peu
plus ou alors s'ils se laissaient
emporter par son pas parce qu'ils les
par son tempérament comme on dit c'est à
dire qu' il ne supporte pas un certain
nombre de contradictions de sujets il
veut choisir il met en scène il savait
qu'il avait une un plateau à sa main
parce que il y avait ses invités les
gens qui étaient là
laplaud décéléré cesser le problème
c'est que moi je trouve ça dommage parce
que c'est certainement quelqu'un qui a
un rôle à jouer il a sa place dans le
paysage politique c'est quelqu'un qui
est un très très bon politique qui est
quelqu'un d'intelligent de cultiver qui
aurait autres je pense qu'ils pourraient
avoir un autre rôle là ils se pour moi
il sert et enfermé mais une manière là à
double tour dans un disons dans un coin
parce qu'il se fait applaudir par c'est
par ces trous par ses disciples mais
marginalisant qui est ce qu'il va
convaincre en humiliant enfin en
humiliant en ce sens humiliant soi même
d'une certaine manière en méprisant
comme ça laurence debré qui est venu qui
qui venait alors elle
bien sûr elle est là une histoire etc et
c'est pas toujours dit dans cette
émission il est toujours un peu un
problème avec les invités le casting du
public 1 on a vu dans d'autres émissions
auparavant des jeunes femmes qui
arrivent et qui était finalement bon
proches d'associations proche des frères
musulmans et c'est avec qui était
présenté comme enseignante et s'éteint
donc il ya toujours un petit problème
sur la présentation ça s'était passé
mais qu'il se rend pas service
mais est ce que moi je vais vous dire ça
sert à ça m'a fait un peu peur en fait
me suis dit le le débat politique ne
gagne pas j'ai trouvé presque
inquiétante cette violence vous avez vu
l'émission qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensez vous moi je vais être très
honnête avec vous j'ai regardé le début
de l'émission parce que j'ai un intérêt
effectivement pour le seul à la chose
politique en général j'ai pas tenu
jusqu'au bout je me suis arrêté
relativement vite parce qu'effectivement
ce
une série de gesticulations de
vociférations que je trouve extrêmement
désagréable effectivement on n'est plus
du tout dans le débat politique la deux
du fond il ne reste absolument rien
c'est à dire qu'on soit d'accord pas
d'accord et jean luc mélenchon je n'y
mets au défi quiconque d'avoir retenu
une idée forte de jean-luc mélenchon
hier pas une issue des sceaux est en
préparation de cette émission j'ai un
petit peu regardé ce qui s'était dit sur
les réseaux sociaux etc
je n'ai pas trouvé un tweet une idée sur
le fou du programme de jean luc
mélenchon ça n'est que effectivement de
des emportements des batailles des
vociférations mai et puis ce
comportement de victimisation
enfin pour ceux qui soutiennent jean luc
mélenchon on a cette victimisation du
leader de la france insoumise sur le
thème il était entouré par les médias
qui lui étaient hostiles etc
mais si ça c'est la stratégie très grave
en attendant cedac en fait on ne on
n'essaie plus de discuter
rationnellement des arguments d'autres
ont le disqualifie en disant vous êtes
vendu au parti socialiste pour une
journaliste vous êtes-vous fait la
propagande des états unis pour quelqu un
c c est en fait peut-être que ça peut
marcher parce que les gens disent ah ben
oui c'est vrai de façon et c'est tous
des menteurs les journalistes il ya des
choses qui sera visé des journalistes
il avait déjà expliqué c'est en 2014 une
interview une grande longue interview
charles qu'il avait décidé de prendre
les journalistes comme punching ball
pour effectivement montré que comme
porte-voix c'est une manière de se poser
en disant moi je ne suis pas comme les
autres ne marche pas dans le système et
je je me confronte avec les journalistes
que je considère comme des adversaires
même façon que je considère juste d'être
versées en politique c'est ce qui l'a
signifié très clairement à chacun
d'entre eux l'anglais ça devient
proverbiale puisqu'à chaque fois c'est
un peu le même cinéma c'est pour ceux
qui suivent elle a pressé le duo avec
l'anglais ça va bientôt faire je sais ça
va bientôt être un numéro de duettiste
humoriste donc mais sinon c'est vrai moi
ce que je ressens c'est intuitif presque
intuition nationale d'un mais quand même
un peu de façon analytique c'est que et
c'est aussi le
le témoignage d'un moment difficile pour
jean luc mélenchon
on est six mois après l'élection du chef
de l'état il a son sa stratégie de
confrontation sociale sur le terrain
social a été un échec
il a essayé de faire porter sa
l'additionnalité il dit que c'est la
faute de la division syndicale
mais c'est aussi un peu son aveuglement
si l huile quand même c'est lui qui
annonce on va être un million sur les
champs-elysées il n'y a personne sur les
champs elysées c'est quand même pas la
cgt ni force ouvrière qui avait qui
avait fait ce pari là donc aider sa mère
il a du mal en de ses aînés autre côté
là où le débat butait c'est le fait
qu'on sait le fait que la france est
soumise elle a rien rien élaboré en tout
cas officiellement depuis son projet
présidentiel
il n'y a rien de neuf à offrir l'essai à
sa mère quand il discute il dit regardez
notre mohlala le message le message
politique de la france a soumise c'est
le projet que j'avais aux
présidentielles j'ai rien d'autre a
montré il en faisant référence à chaque
fois il n'y a pas il n'y a pas d'avancée
donc ils butent un peu sort et il dit en
même temps ben je peux pas aller plus
loin parce qu'un mouvement c'est un
parti c'est un an qu'il est noble et on
ressentait toutes ces contrats né toutes
les contributions personnelles de
jean-luc mélenchon et toutes les quatre
contradictions de la france a soumises
ou et sont apparus bon avec il faut le
dire ddd aux risques n'ont pas fait de
cadeau vraiment non plus parce que c'est
vrai que fait robot nao plus venezuela
bon au bono je comprends parce que c'est
un truc c'est la laïcité une question
importante
franchement moi je suis un peu je donne
un peu raison à jean luc mélenchon le
venezuela
c'est l'étonnant mettant les devine
aisément lui pose la question comment
poser la question où communiste de leur
relation à l'urss dans les années 50
c'est normal ah oui sauf que c'est le
venezuela vous avez vu c'est pas l'union
soviétique vous avez remarqué que les
chars vénézuéliens sont pas quarante
huit heures durant
ça vous dit quelque chose peut-être vous
qui avez connu comme moi cette époque on
disait oui un vrai danger à l'est parce
qu'ils avaient effectivement
potentiellement un danger il n'y a pas
de danger venezuela pour les français ça
et c'est très très loin de la scène
politique français on peut dire celles
qui sont en principe d'accord mais
franchement ce voilà au rebond au bono
s'est enfin elle est la divergence elle
combine wire il ya un vrai problème
politique parce que c'est la laïcité
française ça touche les champs mais
voilà je n'ai pas non plus mardi du
figaro.fr nous a rejoint pour soir mme
ehrman qu'est ce qu'on dit sur les
réseaux sociaux de cette prestation
mélenchonistes et
sensiblement la même chose que ce qu'on
veut entendre de nos trois gravité donc
par rapport à ce que vous disiez laurent
bouvet c'est un peu la même chose les
dans la majorité des internautes
trouvent que jean luc mélenchon est trop
agressif on a notamment sur le figaro.fr
georges abitbol qui nous dit il avait
indéniablement fait une bonne campagne
présidentielle mais depuis c'est la
descente aux enfers pendant l'émission
c'était condescendance et mépris à
l'égard des contradicteurs zéro pointé
qui nous dit le retour j'ai zappé
quelques minutes mélenchon est bon
seulement quand il s'agit de vociférer
en faisant de grands gestes quand il
faut rester calme et poli par contre
sous x qui nous dit cet homme me fait
peur par la manière qu'il a traité ses
contradicteurs insulté caricature à quoi
ça ressemblera s'il devient président un
jour qui sait peter r qui nous dit je
trouve qu'il en a mis plein la tête aux
journalistes et ça ça va bien plus
d'accord mais que venait faire le
venezuela dans le débat sur twitter on
pense sensiblement la même chose
notamment pour le venezuela en dehors du
lapsus que mélenchon avait fait avec eux
danièle obono qu'il qualifiait d'
antiracistes et d'antisémite
c'est ce qui ressortait le plus sur
twitter l'émission politique était le
achetant une émission politique le
hashtag émission politique était l'un
des stades les plus commentés hier soir
et on avait notamment le journaliste
thomas van poucke il me disait et a
quasiment pas un français qui est une
idée précise de ce qui se passe au
venezuela et les missions politiques
jugent utile d'en faire encore une de
ses principales séquences avec mélenchon
et on a également la directrice du bondy
blog nassir el mouallem qui dit quoi que
l'on pense de mélenchon france 2 est
prise dans son propre piège de vouloir
parler du venezuela pour faire le
spectacle
oui cela mérite bien plus que 10 minutes
de clash rien en ressort zéro pointé et
dans tous les tweets qu'on pouvait voir
on parlait surtout de la forme et jamais
du fond aude lancelin journalistes aussi
qui nous dit léa salamé sur mélenchon
vous avez l'impression que c'est du duo
est l'idiot utile pascal bruckner plutôt
une potiche talentueuse léa salamé
vous en pensez-quoi bernard kouchner la
télé publique en 2017 et enfin lantoine
les moments qui nous dit chez france 2
avant l'émission on reçoit qui ce soir
déjà
mélenchon je vous laisse voir l'image
cool on va pouvoir faire n'importe quoi
ça va être bien harati un regard le
visuel que j'ai fait à excellent on
mettra ça dès le début pour mettre une
ambiance
merci mais je voudrais juste rappeler
quelque chose avant c'est que la plupart
des réactions sur twitter en fait sont
des journalistes sous notre article
avait 600 commentaires mais même nos
internautes disent en fait on n'a pas
regardé l'émission on en parle
maintenant qu'on voit les extraits et
pour rappeler les missions politiques
est arrivé 4
meyer dans les audiences derrière tf1
derrière m6 mais aussi de france 3 est
un village français juste juste injuste
s'assure j'ai vu les j'ai eu
connaissance des chiffres d'audience ce
matin c'est pas étonnant parce que en
fait cette émission qui le servait dans
la période avant la présidentielle où il
faisait des bons scores c'était la même
chose pour marine le pen qui avait fait
un mauvais score qui a fait l'émission
depuis la présidentielle et qui a fait
aussi un mauvais score
ce sont des gens qui étaient servis par
cette émission qui était une mission
justement il y avait un peu de spectacle
politique une mise en scène avec
différents moments et c est aujourd'hui
sont desservis parce qu'on est dans une
période où on a besoin de structures une
opposition au président à la majorité
etc
or là on a vu en dehors du cas du
venezuela et ça a été dit de danièle
obono que je laisse de côté même par
rapport à la jeune chef d'entreprise
on voyait jean luc mélenchon ne pouvait
pas dialoguer avec elle alors là c'est
pas qu'il a rejetée par mépris comme
avec laurence debré sur le venezuela
c'est qu'en fait lui partait de
généralités il était sur son programme
présidentiel elle donnait une expérience
et on voyait bien sûr mais la réforme
sur le rail sur les prud'hommes
notamment pour les malades et les
indemnités aux prud'hommes elle avait eu
une expérience justement qu'elle
racontait aux prud'hommes et on voyait
qu'il n'y avait pas dire le possible
parce que il
il est pas dans le bon tempo il est
encore ce que vous disiez au début sur
la présidentielle donc là cette émission
là arrivent comme quelque chose qui
vient à la fois trop tard ou trop tôt
par rapport à une éventuelle autre
candidature un autre moment peu d'avancé
et donc toutes ces séquences étaient un
peu étrange c'est à dire que haye et les
contradictions au bono il ya le
venezuela qui lui revient dessus alors
que bon il avait parlé d' alliance
bolivarienne etc enfin ça fait plus
partie effectivement du débat politique
aujourd'hui il n'était pas à l'aise sur
le fond il répétait à françois lenglet
ces propositions de campagne
on voyait que ça finalement il est on
savait pas pourquoi ils étaient largeur
de l'institutional je fais un sondage
sur sur mélenchon se passe quand il est
ressenti c'est pas très très bon c'est
un triste automne pour jean luc
mélenchon est donc le sondage que l'on a
fait il ya une semaine corrobore ou
préparent finalement tout ce que l'on a
vu hier cette émission ne changeant pas
grand chose
jean luc mélenchon en deux mois a chuté
de six points
c'est désormais 63% des français qui ont
désormais une môme une mauvaise image de
jean luc mélenchon et parmi les items
qui sont les plus ressorti il y en a 60
9% qui considèrent qu'il est agressif et
68% qu'il joue trop perso
évidemment ce qu'on lui reproche
derrière c'est deux choses c'est
évidemment la manière dont il ne s'est
pas opposée au premier réforme macron ça
on le sait bien d'ailleurs il l'a
reconnu il a dit que c'était une erreur
derrière n'est en tout cas il a reconnu
qu'il n'y était pas arrivé et puis et
puis il y a aussi peut-être une petite
musique la manière dont on le les
français ont été très choqués par toutes
les histoires autour des proches de jean
luc mélenchon l'histoire avec simonet
l'histoire avec garrido et donc
toussaint finalement ça ça ameute h
sas avait sa vertu donc il reste le
premier tribun il reste l'opposant de
jean luc mélenchon mais mais mais en
même temps c'est un très triste automne
et je pense pas que cette émission
change grand chose
bon bah écoutez le vol habillé pour
l'hiver on va peut-être un peu en paix
c'est pour jean luc mélenchon
le figaro publié ce matin une étude de
d'un think tank américain qui s'appelle
pew research center sur la projection de
ce que pourrait être
le pourcentage de musulmans dans la
population française en 2050
l'étude 10 pour être en fonction de la
politique d'immigration entre 12 7 mais
plus probablement 17,4 voire 18 % contre
8 % et quelques aujourd'hui c'est quand
même un bouleversement assez majeur et
pourtant ce sont des sujets qui sont
assez peu traité laurent bouvet est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un paradoxe là dedans je
sais que vous l'avez lu attentivement si
oui alors ce jeu depuis très longtemps
je lis les études les différentes étude
du pew research center est des gens
sérieux
ce sont des gens très sérieux qui font
des recherches qu'on appelle
longitudinale sur beaucoup de sujets
beaucoup d'argent c'est un c'est un
centre ça fait partie de ces justement
c'est le think tank qui sont pas dans
l'université mais qui sont des centres
de recherche très sérieux et ils ont un
centre sur l'islam et l'évolution des
populations musulmanes qui travaille
depuis des années donc c'est très très
sérieux là c'est leur grande enquête qui
est qui paraît je crois tous les deux ou
trois ans qui vient de se faire long
qu'en focalisant sur l'évolution de la
population en europe à 2050 avec
différents scénarios peut-être qu'on le
voit sur les les
les graphiques que vous montrez vous
avez les scénarios à immigration zéro
vous avez des scénarios à ouverture
moyenne ou l'ouverture super un peu plus
élevé d'immigration en tout cas dans
tous les scénarios une augmentation très
importante dans tous les pays de la
population de confession musulmane
confession culture je laisse le débat de
côté pour le moment là la question que
ça pose au fond c'est très intéressant
parce que c'est d'abord celle que vous
posez qui est la première c'est à dire
que c'est un sujet dont on parle très
peu dans le débat public
on en a peu parlé pendant la
présidentielle pour une raison
conjoncturelle c'est que les candidats
qui auraient pu parler de cette question
à gauche on peut penser à manuel valls
éliminé aux primaires à droite à
françois fillon
c'est ce qui lui est arrivé et de
manière plus traditionnelle marine le
pen qui n'a pas fait campagne sur ces
questions pour se consacrer plutôt à
l'euro et à la question
européenne donc n'ont pas mis au centre
de ce débat ce qui aurait pu aurait dû
le faire ne l'ont pas fait et les autres
candidats éviter cette question et ça a
été les candidats qui en ont plutôt
bénéficié non jean luc mélenchon
évidemment emmanuel macron donc on a eu
un débat tronqué
alors que c'est une préoccupation
essentielle hier soir dans l'émission de
jean luc mélenchon et il y avait eu
quelques éléments d'un sondage que
présentait brice teinturier sur la
laïcité menacé par exemple ça c'est
quasiment trois quarts de nos
concitoyens qui disent que la laïcité
aujourd'hui est menacée en france
qu'elle est en danger pas menacées en
danger plus précisément soyons précis
donc il ya des préoccupations très
importante et le deuxième élément très
rapidement c'est que en fait ça pose on
parle toujours des nouveaux clivages de
la recomposition politique mais là là on
a des nouveaux clivages
on a une réponse à cette montée
potentielle ce qui va arriver
démographique migratoire de la
population de culture ou de confession
musulmane
première réponse la réponse des
populisme d'extrême droite notamment
france du front national des des
populismes identitaire comme on dit
aujourd'hui qui sont situés à droite ou
à l'extrême droite en europe
il y en a de différentes sortes qui
existent en ordre leurs réponses et de
dire c'est fini
il ya une civilisation européenne qui
est chrétienne qui vient de loin et
cetera
il faut la défendre on est dans un choc
des civilisations refuse l'islamisation
ça c'est une réponse en face une réponse
qui est la réponse européenne classique
celle du président macron celle d'un
certain nombre de chefs d'état et ses
acquis et de dire c'est pas finalement
un problème il faut qu'on ait une zone
de croissance suffisante et on peut
accueillir ont pas tous les migrants
évidemment non pas toute la misère du
monde comme disait michel rocard mais
enfin on peut appuyer en notre part et
ça va se passer
le pari dans gala merkel il y a deux ans
etc
et il ya une réponse qui est qui
existent mais qui - présente et qui est
un enjeu fondamental c'est à dire que
ces gens qu'on va accueillir qui
viennent d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'on va
leur demander qu'est ce qu'on va leur
demander est ce qu'on les laisse à
devenir comme eux comme ils sont pas
revanche fini juste là tu ou alors est
ce qu'on dit on les laisse entrer on en
laisse
nous sommes à un continent ou vers des
pays ouvert mais à ce moment là il faut
qu'ils respectent un certain nombre de
règles
deux principes appel l'intégration
l'assimilation est ce que il ya une
forme de deux
de peur de la classe politique hormis
effectivement marine le pen de parler de
ce sujet alors que oui c'est quand même
un bouleversement considérable l'a
d'abord j'ai pas pu aller voir en détail
j'ai juste j'ai lu l'article du figaro
je trouve que fait michel c'est d'accord
sexuelle c'est quand même le débat au
fond que les politiques et vite
et d'ailleurs même au fond quand on les
regarde ce que du front national il crie
beaucoup mais il n'y a pas beaucoup de
fond quand on regarde le travail qu'ils
font c'est ils ont bien compris que -
plus été caricatural et moi c'était
approfondie mais ça marchait dans la
victoire je vais dire trois choses la
première c'est que si on comprend bien
et d'abord sator un peu le coup grands
emplacements serre en 2050 on est haut à
18 % maximum
la deuxième chose que veut dire ce qui
n'est pas dans le pew réellement passé
c'est le cas une population musulmane va
placerait envers la population française
dit de souche d'accord maintenant 17 %
c'est aussi une part importante de la
population c'est pas c'est pas une part
négligeable ce ne serait pas moi je ne
parle croix pour communauté mais si
c'était une communauté se serait pas une
petite communauté
justement est-ce que ça va être une
communauté ou pas est-ce que ce n'est
pas dans le c'est pas mal du tout dans
les projections pas ce que ça veut dire
est ce que les gens qui sont rentrés il
ya 20 ans ils seront encore des
musulmans comme ils sont rentrés il ya
vingt ans à l'horizon 2050 whisky sont
pas tout simplement sécularisée
assimilés et c'est naturellement et
deuxièmement part éventuellement une
politique adaptée est ce qu'on fait et
voilà ça c'est un quotient troisièmement
il ya des choses qui sont dix ans s'est
pas vu quand on travaille le cuir et
sert que l'on prend par exemple le taux
de fécondité ça ça fait très peur c'est
le saas est grand et plus rentable que
chaque entité donc on affiche enfin on
affiche on calcule à tout rompre unités
j'imagine que c'est sérieux de 2,4
enfants par femme de culture ou de
religion musulmane contre 1,9 pour
lorient la relation d'abord un on sait
les démos à vous le disent en général il
ya quand même une courbe quand on arrive
dans un pays en général ça il ya une
adaptation à la rumeur du pays
et donc si la transition démographique
il faut voir emmanuel todd et
deuxièmement là aussi on a l'impression
qu'on ne peut pas agir dessus
or la politique réagit nous avons une
politique je donnais juste un exemple
très précis nous avons une politique
familiale qui a été ce qui est un
compromis fait notamment avec avec les
églises notamment les églises
catholiques pour favoriser les familles
nombreuses notamment le troisième enfant
enfin en vertu de quoi nous fait nous
avons en effet maintenant une politique
était qui a été fait il ya maintenant
une quarantaine d'années une
cinquantaine d'années sûr qu'elle y
avait un consensus
le résultat c'est quoi c'est
qu'effectivement nous favorisons les
familles nombreuses qui sont maintenant
effectivement des familles de dd donc
avec des instruments des subventions
c'est pas notre mot qui viennent
favorise effectivement là le fait qu'ils
aient pas de transition démographique
danser dans ces populations là alors
qu'en fait nous ne donnons par exemple
une subvention dont très peu le premier
enfant alors que nous savons que le
problème démographique de la population
actuelle de français c'est de faire le
premier enfant beaucoup trop tard donc
non donc la politique que nous menons
est une politique qui accentue
éventuellement on peut la corriger choix
que l'on peut très bien vous arrêtez de
voiliers de favoriser les familles nos
et favoriser le premier et favoriser la
naissance du premier enfant le plus tôt
possible chez les femmes actuelles
pascoe par ailleurs on sait que les
problèmes de fécondité il ya aussi les
problèmes médicaux les points de
fécondité que connaissent les
populations actuelles c'est le fait qu'
il ya un retard de plus en plus grand de
las de l'année sans expérience en
question il me trompe pas cette question
ce sont quelque chose politique c'est
pas simplement contre le front national
pour le front national est ce qu'on est
anti immigrés et anti immigration qui
musulmans ce sont des choix de politique
publique ce que vient d'illustrer hervé
nathan est exactement la question qu'est
ce qu'on choisit et de fermer grâce quel
type d'immigration et qu'elle d'accueil
est encore en réalisant le loup on
intègre dans le choix des politiques
publiques dans les courbes qu'on a vu il
ya quelque chose de très intéressant sur
le cas français par rapport au reste de
l'europe c'est que dans le cas français
on n'a pas une grande différence entre
le scénario médian est le scénario
autodafé ça c'est peut-être le relais
oui mais il parle c'est par rapport à
passer par rapport au passé c'est à dire
que on a comme on a déjà une population
de confession ou de culture musulmane
installée importante et un taux de
fécondité relativement élevé de toute
façon cette progression il existera
qu'on ouvre davantage les portes ou pas
ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
dédramatiser le sujet de l'ouverture des
frontières françaises par rapport à
d'autres de cela il ya quand même une
progression bien moindre on le voit sur
la coupe et qu'on montre 12% au lieu de
18 pour quoi je parle d'aidé entre les
deux scénarios le scénario moyen que
scénario
voilà deuxième sujet qui me paraît
intéressant dessus pour relativiser
cette comparé à d'autres pays européens
effectivement pour nous il ya une vraie
voilà on voit la position française
aujourd'hui qu'après qui est assez
élevés entre guillemets dans ce palmarès
si on peut appeler ça comme ça on voit
les pays du nord les pays scandinaves
qui vont avoir une modification de la
structure sociale il sera beaucoup plus
importante je pense en ressenti que pour
nous on sent quand même le pays d'europe
qui avec la communauté musulmane la plus
importante en pourcentage de la
population derrière la suède a en
arriverait peut être le scénario ensuite
c'est 30% c'est un tiers de la
population s'ils continuent avec une
politique d'ouverture de la finlande est
aussi benjamin grange ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que le chiffre est
finalement cette étude donne l'occasion
de parler du sujet or on voit bien que
les politiques sont un peu dans une
impasse d'une impasse parce que ils ont
du mal à se positionner et quand on
regarde les réseaux sociaux et la
manière dont les français en parlent
là encore on retrouve le même casse-tête
c'est à dire ce soit une position soit
finalement des ex des extrêmes qui
s'opposent et d'ailleurs qui se voit là
qu'ils se tirent un peu dans la dans les
pattes soit finalement une position où
on aborde le sujet sans l'aborder bref
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de pudeur et
finalement c'est peut-être à travers le
fait est l'étude que ce sujet on va
pouvoir en parler de les mettre sur la
table le sujet n'est pas forcément
abordé en dynamique mais j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est quand même dans
le débat public sur la capacité de la
société française intégrée notamment aux
accusations envers les agences
assimilation et et inclusion commandé
aujourd'hui à l'autre extrême il n'est
pas posée une manière disons comme une
généralité en pop comme la politique qui
généralise les enjeux il est posé avec
des morceaux par exemple on se focalise
un moment donné sur l'islamisme radical
et la pression que que l'islamisme
radical fait peser à certains moments
sur certains enjeux on se focalise sur
la crise des migrants au moment où il a
créé des migrants on dit attention les
migrants etc
on se focalise sur un certain nombre de
deux
micro sujet mais sans jamais voir comme
disent nos amis anglo-saxons de global
pictures c'est à dire l'image générale
la vue générale
or c'est ça qui nous manque et c'est
tout l'intérêt de cette étude c'est de
nous montrer effectivement que c'est un
mouvement qui n'est pas seulement
d'abord qui est inquiétant qui est en
dynamique et il faut réfléchir sur parce
qu'on dit souvent que la démographie est
la seule de sciences humaines qui soit
une science exacte puisque on peut faire
des prévisions assez greenzer en fait ça
c'est faux et à l'épaule les projections
démographiques on sait qu'elle bouge
celles qui sont faites on l'a on en ut
pont
il ya même le nom de gens pensent qu'ils
seront présents sur terre le nombre
d'humains de frais non sur terre neuve
dans dix quinze vingt ans on ne s'est
pas du tout est exact parce que vous
disiez tout fécondité évolué membracides
est sûr c'est que sur la question de
l'immigration ou son mode au sel débat
qu on s et on ferme on ferme pas à
l'entraînement voilà et le reste c'est
un peu incantatoire
il faut exiger à 6,6 faut exiger cela
est en fait nous avons des instruments
de politique publique c'est ce que je
voulais souligner soit sur la politique
familiale éventuellement sur la laïcité
il ya des possibilités enfin il ya un
vol aller nous avons à la fois un état
une administration une démocratie qui
sont là pour agir
pas simplement pour contempler les flux
migratoires sur le territoire et bien
rendez vous en 2050 pour savoir si le
pew research center avait ou non réseau
ainsi la démographie est une science
exacte pour revenir au sujet qui nous
opposaient lorsqu'il ya des gens qui
s'intéressent beaucoup ce thème là ce
sont les électeurs de la droite et du
centre
nous les avons interviewé dans un
sondage kantar sofres pour le figaro
magazine de ce week end les
sympathisants lr et udi donc de la
droite et du centre met en premier de
très loin le thème de la maîtrise de
l'immigration comme comme parmi ceux qui
doivent être portées par la droite dans
les années à venir mais aussi très haut
le la lutte contre la délinquance et
l'insécurité dont on va dire une des
électeurs de droite qui sont assez à
droite et en même temps qu'ils sont pas
opposée à des rapprochements avec la
république en marche 45% des
sympathisants aient l'air et udi sont
ainsi favorables à une liste commune ou
à des listes communes
oui à une liste commune pardon en marche
les républicains pour les élections
européennes suivent en cela l'idée
suggérée par alain juppé est ce que vous
voyez là une contradiction hervé nathan
entre des gens qui sont assez à droite
et en même temps qu'ils sont assez en
marche des gens qui sont assez adroite
remarque que les gens marchent font une
petite de drogue pour en bonne partie
par ailleurs ils sont quand même pour ce
qui concerne les européennes s'il ya une
grande partie de la de la droite
traditionnelle des électeurs la droite
traditionnelle qui sont acquis à l'idée
européenne qui sont pas pour remettront
et qui suivront difficilement à l'heure
aux banquiers qui dit on va remettre un
coup des traités faire faire une europe
des 6 et aya voilà il ya quand même une
partie de cet électorat là qui est
disponible effectivement pour une espèce
de grande masse dauphin de grandes
listes centristes écrasant sur sa gauche
et à sa droite n'avait à sa gauche
mélenchon sav parti socialiste surtout
pris en valeur pour le coup le casse toi
êtes il est redoutable et eram nord vous
qui l'avez faisant reflux évoqué vers le
front national je pense que oui il ya
des gens qui seront disponibles pour ça
il reste à dire que dans le dernier
baromètre
quant à sofres pour le figaro magazine
toujours ce week-end c'est à droite que
emmanuel macron progresse il ya
aujourd'hui un fossé entre sa popularité
chez les sympathisants socialistes sa
fille chez les sympathisants
ça n'a pas l'air de vous surprendre
bercy va ya non effectivement c'est pas
très surprenant en particulier sur le
sujet des européennes faut se souvenir
aussi que pour ceux des électeurs de
droite qui effectivement se montrent
inquiets à l'idée européenne et se
souvenir de la présidentielle
ou quand même certains se sont fait très
peur quand on voyait le paysage
monde la présidentielle avec une
quantité importante de candidats qu'ils
étaient prêts à remettre en cause la
construction européenne telle qu'on l'a
connue qui était prêt à ne pas
rembourser la dette et a provoqué une
crise absolument majeur au niveau
européen ça allait évidemment de
jean-luc mélenchon à marine le pen en
passant par benoît hamon qui osent lui
aussi avait des idées s'arrêter sur la
question donc sur ce sujet européen qui
ait un rapprochement
d'idées entre la droite et mâcon ça me
paraissait ça me paraît logique et après
effectivement dans ce que fait emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui avec edouard philippe
ça aide d'avoir à avoir des
rapprochements val jeu dans la
formulation de votre question moi je
vois pas fonctionnement de la
contradiction
j'ai envoyé une laurent bouvet parce que
la maîtrise de l'immigration
c'est un sujet dont emmanuel macron ne
parle absolument jamais mais apparemment
les électeurs de droite ne lui en
tiennent pas grief mais parce qu'en fait
ce ce sondage c'est en fait illustre le
problème de laurent wauquiez
c'est à dire que qu'il va avoir une
difficulté si quand il parle des sujets
économiques européens ça vient d'être
évoqué l'immense majorité des électeurs
de droite sont des électeurs qu'on va
appeler conservateur mais sur le plan
donc conservatisme positive car ils
veulent garder l'union européenne ils ne
veulent pas toucher le lay à l'est la
question des retraités la question de la
sécurité de deux des rémunérations delà
de ce qu'on appelle la rente etc qui est
un enjeu considérable
et puis quand il s'agit des valeurs
alors là au sens des valeurs familiales
culturelles etc
on a identitaire même et dix alors
préserver les calanques et français
voilà les identitaires il ya deux choses
c'est toujours compliqué il ya les
valeurs familiales lives et j'ai les
droits des homosexuels le demain
peut-être la gpa etc etc
toutes ces questions l'euthanasie etc et
puis il ya les questions nationales
d'identité de frontières qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec l'immigration
que sommes-nous qu'est ce que ça veut
dire être français aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il ya une identité chrétienne ou pas
etc etc
donc ces questions là ne sont pas tout à
fait sûr traités de la même manière et
sur ces questions en revanche les mêmes
électeurs qui veulent garder conserver
le cadre européen qui ont peur pour leur
avenir qui ont aussi ce que moi j'ai
appelé avec d'autres la sécurité
culturelle c'est à dire que leur peur
par rapport à l'avenir où ils veulent
garder un cadre assez stable
économiquement surtout pas remettre en
cause que j'ai très bien du magazine
tout à l'heure le cadre actuel parce
qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'on ce qu'on on
sait ce qu'on perd mais on ne sait pas
ce qu'on pourrait gagner et bien
ils ont très peur aussi qu'il y ait des
modifications dont on parlait juste
avant avec la question de l'augmentation
de la population musulmane et ça c'est
une contradiction parce que
effectivement il ya une partie qui n'est
pas traitée par le centre-droit par
emmanuel macron or là laurent wauquiez
devra gagner des électeurs sur le fn
s'il veut s'appuyer sur ce genre de
question donc live est dans une
quadrature du cercle où il va avoir à
garder une bonne partie de ses électeurs
à sa gauche au centre droit et à
conquérir une partie des électeurs du fn
comme l'avait fait par exemple nicolas
sarkozy en 2007 alors la question pas
facile non c'est pas facile
comment on peut s'en sortir laurent
wauquiez écoutez les conseils que lui
donne notre confrère ivan rioufol le
chroniqueur au figaro bien connu c'était
dans l'émission les décrypteurs je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut une radicalité et
je crois que les ceux qui se font
entendre aujourd'hui sont alors vous qui
est naturellement avec cette radicalité
que je l'encouragent à assumer mais
également manuel valls qui également
sort un petit peu de la léthargie du
socialisme pur également s'affirmer dans
des grands sujets identitaires ou hugo
ou civilisationnel qui ne sont pas
abordés qui ne seront pas abordés par le
maquereau nisme et je pense que l'avenir
est à ce positionnement la reine attend
vous avez en commun avec l'envol un goût
pour les plus l'enlever bordeaux est-ce
que sur les idées vous êtes aussi
d'accord avec lui
je pense qu'il ya là je pense qu'il ya
une tentation je pense que je suis pas
sûr que les conseils de votre notre ami
rioufol soient les bons d'un côté je
suis mal placé pour donner conseils je
pense que par exemple sur un thème de
radicalité par exemple manuel valls qui
a fait une sortie tonitruante qu'il a
effectivement tirer un peu du un peu du
fond du trou il était depuis l'élection
de cette présidentielle puis initiative
a dû quand même présenté quasiment ses
excuses sur la manière dont il parlait
du danger de l'islam pour la france au
lieu de parler de l'islamisme donc il
faut faire attention à ça jamais se
laisser déborder quand on fait quand
même un jury comme j'ai posé la question
je pense déclaration l'espèce en
déclarations l'espagne et un espagnol
oui il a dit avait un problème avec les
musulmans français avec aucun moment on
finit par déborder dragin grange
en fait la vraie question c'est quel est
l'espace qui reste alors invoqué quand
on regarde en fait les réseaux sociaux
tous les thèmes sur lequel finalement la
droite est attendue sont des thèmes que
traite emmanuel macron si on met de côté
peut-être la politique familiale qui est
le quel point un peu de côté mais sinon
c'est tout et donc quand on regarde la
manière dont les français on parle et
notamment les sympathisants dit de
droite on s'aperçoit que ils sont un peu
perdus perdu dans ses codes qui sont
véritablement brouillés et surtout perdu
parce que ben j'ai eu le premier
ministre il égrène de droite nice de
l'industrie il ya un mélange des genres
qui fait qu' on essaie difficile de
retrouver de retrouver ses petits et
donc finalement ses sympathisants de
droite ils n'ont aucune griefs
qualitatif en fait vis-à-vis de macron
et donc on retrouve finalement c'est
l'immigration sur ces questions à l'abri
sur des choses sur la famille évidemment
rien sur la famille avec ça c'est pas
net on va trouver effectivement sur
l'islam en fait mais sur le ce qui fait
finalement la majeure partie des des
attendus de la droite
là-dessus il n'y a pas tellement de
critiques de la politique de macro sur
le sujet l'immigration il ya une petite
séquence récente des manuels macron face
à une jeune marocaine
de mémoire voilà qu'il y avait que je
penserai plus séduire une partie danger
chez vous donc vous devriez peut-être
rentrer au maroc risque était de pouvoir
capacités au gaz il aimait à dire les
choses clairement et s'approcherait au
moins avec ce land ça se voit l'art est
insolent des léonards d'agen 2 et
maintenant nous allons vous expliquer
comment devenir riche
peut-être avec le bitcoin vous savez
cette monnaie virtuelle qui a été créé
en 2011 sa valeur depuis lors par trente
mille et par 10 depuis le début de
l'année petit sondage rapide est ce que
au temps à table
certains d'entre vous ont acheté des
bitcoins ou en possède apparemment non
oui oui parce qu'on a raccompagné
parfois des sociétés qui font des levées
de fonds hobbit colle donc oui on est
familier familier mais ces voix là on
n'est pas morts on n'est pas très
nombreux berti ce qui est formidable
quand on lit votre article c'est que
tout le monde économique alors racontez
nous un 35 secondes qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce que c'est que cette
monnaie pourquoi ça atteint des sommets
comme ça et puis est-ce que ce qu'il
faut en acheter pour essayer de profiter
de la hausse en 30 secondes
à 35 ans allez soyons simples le bitcoin
c'est donc une monnaie virtuelle qui a
été créé par un algorithme alors il ya
énormément de mystère et de mystique
autour de ça on sait pas exactement créa
qui a créé un algorithme mais en tout
cas cet tags eurythmie créer une monnaie
que les gens peuvent acheter sur des
sites spécialisés pays pourquoi est-ce
que ça s'est emballée comme ça il ya un
effet de mode il y à l'acceptation au
fur et à mesure par différents sites par
différents producteurs de services ou de
deux produits de cette monnaie comme
effectivement une valeur des changes
donc à partir du moment où on est sur
une valeur d'échangé effective ça prend
un caractère monétaire quelque part et
donc les gens veulent en avoir pour
acheter échanger vendre des choses et
puis il ya un effet de rareté qui est en
train d'arriver parce que cet algorithme
qu'on a créé on sait une chose de lui
c'est qu'à 21 millions d'unités il
s'arrêtera on doit être à 17 18 millions
aujourd'hui donc cette fabrication de
monnaie virtuelle bientôt elle va
prendre fin et forcément quand on voit
arriver la rareté la valeur montre
alors je vous propose d'écouter ce qu'on
dit notre prix nobel jean tirole prix
nobel d'économie en 2014 dans une
interview au financial times lui n'est
pas très enthousiaste sur sur le beach
boys d'abord il regrette que ce soit
utilisée souvent pour l'évasion fiscale
ou le blanchiment d'argent j'espère
benjamin gans je n'ai pas à ses
activités que vous voilà il faut
s'exercer avec les beatles mais vous
allez nous l'expliqué et en disant
attention les gouvernements devraient
protéger leurs citoyens contre des
développements risquent et socialement
nuisible
hervé nathan j'imagine que vous partagez
cet alarmisme vous suivent non je ne
partage pas les larmes je voudrais juste
revenir un petit peu là
la génèse du bitcoin le bim coyne l'est
on peut en juste au lendemain de la
grande crise financière 2007/2008 sont
dit on c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
mystère mais le prochain il ya un projet
politique dit-on au départ des bitcoins
et de se passer des étapes se passait
des banques et c'est vraiment d'une
certaine manière c'est une monnaie moi
je conteste le mode mais cela maintenant
c'est un moyen de paiement anarchiste au
centre pas de pouvoir donc les banques
ne doivent plus on va pouvoir parce
qu'elles sont ils devenus enfin ils sont
la crise financière fait que les plus
personne ne peut croire dans ces banques
et d'une certaine manière les
libertariens en plus que libertaire
d'ailleurs disent regarder personne ne
peut faire confiance à évidemment on
peut jamais faire confiance et l'état ça
c'est le sait le projet politique d'une
certaine manière la spéculation qui est
en train de s'emparer du bitcoin est en
train de montrer que ce projet politique
est peut-être en train de dérailler
parce qu à 323 milliards de
de l'art d'équivalent bitcoin de stock
de bill gates
c'est l'équivalent actuel de skier en
stock s'il ya une grosse
il ya un gros crac dessus il peut y
avoir des dégâts qui peuvent entraîner
fait quelque chose on sait pas pas
systémique n'est pas tarder vous je sais
pas c'est pas non plus par rapport à la
masse du système financier
rien n'est fait pour monter des coups
que je gagne a dit le bitcoin c'est un
peu comme une pyramide de ponzi
les premiers qui rentre on faire des
gros profits et les dan acheteurs
perdront beaucoup d'arabes possible
c'est possible et c'est possible aussi
que effectivement les premiers les
initiateurs parce que personne ne
connaît les secteurs est stocké
suffisamment de big oil pour moment ce
sera tout temps ont tous retirés et
avant que ça ces fontes tous transformés
en dollars ou en bon vieux euros
notre bonne vieille monnaie qui elle est
garantie par une bonne centrale c'est la
différence
l'autre de ski moi ce qui est fascinant
dans cette histoire là pour moi c'est
que il ya des gens très sérieux et des
entreprises et des institutions qui se
prêtent à ce jeu là c'est ça qu'est le
plus fascinant c'est que normalement il
est dehors et c'était le calcul des
banques centrales à l'époque ce soit la
fed ou là où la mangue ou la bce s'était
dit on va de fait on va les ignorer et
on va le faire en sorte que ça reste
enfouie comme ça ça reste totalement
marginal est en fait ils n'ont pas
réussi à pas même des entreprises des
sociétés qui viennent là dessus et qui
s'endettent en bitcoin en prenant des
risques qui peuvent être considérables
c'est un échec
le grand public est là maintenant si
vous voulez partir au venezuela par
exemple en ce moment c'est une bonne
idée
c'est une bonne idée de se servir du
bitcoin juste comme moyen de
transmission de l'amener parce que en ce
moment ça coûte extrêmement cher d'aller
de faire un transfert d'argent en
dollars ou en euros au made in usa pour
les réseaux institutionnels qu'on
connaît en revanche en bitcoin et c'est
un des avantages du moyen de paiement
c'est extrêmement peu cher vous avez une
commission tout petit lorsque vous
transformez 100 euros je me suis 100
pesos 3 au venezuela
alors que si vous le faites en passant
par le de là ça va vous coûter une
fortune
ça m'arrange je me disais que vouliez
vous avez des clients qui utilisent et
le pit conne qu'est ce qu'ils en font on
n'a pas des clients qui l'utilisent
en fait derrière le bitcoin
dont le comment dire le cours est assez
élevé et ça correspond finalement à la
rareté ou où nombre de bitcoin qui
restent qui reste à acheter on a
évidemment quelque chose qui est
respectée très spéculatif peu réglementé
et qui évidemment à haut risque par
contre
voilà quoi un peu règlements sont pas
réglementées et en tout cas à très haut
risque ce qui est intéressant c'est
finalement que le bitcoin est
illustratif finalement d'une technologie
qui elle est intéressante et je rejoins
avait quand il disait qu'il y avait une
logique un peu sociétal derrière d'avoir
quelque chose de beaucoup plus
horizontal où finalement entre
l'émetteur et le récepteur celui qui
fait la transaction
moi je vais payer par exemple chez un
commerçant quand je paye avec ma carte
bancaire il ya un tiers qui assure les
choses et bien le finalement toutes ces
technologies liées à la blocs chain et
lier la bitcoin en est l'illustration et
bien vise à se passer de ce tiers de
confiance et donc derrière implicitement
derrière cette monnaie là il ya la
volonté que demain quand on achèterait
un appartement pour partie une partie de
la transaction peut se passer du notaire
que demain plutôt d'utiliser une
plateforme pour commander un chauffeur
comment dire un vtc et bien on peut
utiliser une technologie et par là même
il ya une forme de court circuitage d'un
certain nombre de choses qui existent et
notamment de ses grandes plateformes
digitales
c'est ça qui est un peu l'ironie de
voile à l'ironie du revient sur locke
est alors qu'adam smith
oui comme toujours quand il ya un marché
il ya un certain nombre d'entrepreneurs
qui qui qui veulent lever de l'argent ça
peut se faire aussi envie de coyne et
donc on a ce type de demande
photos nettes en france il y en a eu
quatre ou cinq jusqu'à présent donc
c'est pour vous dire que c'est quand
même plutôt quelque chose de rare en
tout cas ça ressemble assez critique il
ya heureusement qu'il nous dit le
bitcoin est un est un objet de
spéculation elle s'effondrera un jour ou
l'autre tendue que flou du plan new deal
va former une belle bulle qui éclatera
un jour comme la bulle internet des
années 2000 alors négocié en direct
on peut jeudi on est en train d'avoir on
dirait que cette bulle se forme et je
regarde la cour vous citiez les chiffres
en début d'émission
c'est assez facile vraiment c'est ce que
ça va véhiculer derrière c'est à dire
oui il ya un côté spéculatif
mais derrière tout tous les tous les
organismes financiers toutes les banques
toutes les compagnies nation s'intéresse
aux technologies guerrières
parce que là il ya quelque chose qui est
probablement qui risque de changer la
manière dont on fait finalement une
partie du commercial ça c'est ça c'est
ce qu'on appelle la blood chaîne et on
vous en parlera le jour où j'aurai
compris pour l'instant ce n'est pas le
cas donc je me hasarderai pas sur ce
terrain laurent bouvet si on fait de la
politique de minutes
en fait c'est peut-être un des derniers
instruments de souveraineté des états
qui est en train de leur échapper parce
que même la monnaie alors nous on a
mutualisé l'autre monnaie avec la zone
euro mais il ya des grandes entreprises
les fameux gafa qui sont aussi puissants
que des états et maintenant le système
privé numérique virtuel est même en
train d'inventer sa mère et moi bon là
je suis totalement ignorants je vous
écoute avec beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêt
j'apprends plein de choses mais ce que
ça me
ce à quoi ça me fait penser c'est qu'on
est c'est la grande question qui se pose
aussi pour la démocratie
quand on parle de postes démocratie on
est en train de rentrer dans un monde où
la démocratie
le capitalisme et l'économie de marché
avec la régulation étatique et les
débats sur plus ou moins de régulation
qu'on a connue pendant en gros deux
siècles est en train on est en train de
sortir de ce monde on ne sait absolument
pas dans quoi on rentre c'est aussi ce
que moi j'appelle un lâche des identités
et l'âge identitaire donc on est en
train de rentrer dans quelque chose
d'assez nouveau avec tout un tas c'était
très intéressant d'entendre il ya une
des idées effectivement de subversion de
renouvellement des institutions etc qui
sont assez intéressantes mais aussi avec
des risques considérables donc si on
fait le compte là de tout les sujets
qu'on abordait le le rapport du pew
research les la question des populismes
du rapport au populisme l'ailé ces
questions de où on veut se passer de
l'état la souveraineté qui commença qui
s'effondre par pans entiers 1 comme une
falaise attaqué par la menace et à on
est quand même dans un monde qui est en
train de bouger à vitesse grand v si on
y ajoute la maîtrise quand même du big
data des données par ces grands acteurs
sans régulation ccc à la fois
passionnant et un chouïa inquiétant
alors je vous propose de nous raccrocher
à quelque chose de bien tangible chers
amis vous ne le savez pas parce que
l'information est tombée depuis début de
l'émission la france pour la coupe du
monde de football sera dans la même
poule que le danemark l'australie et le
pérou je vous avoue sans fausse honte de
ne rien connaître à ce sujet est-ce que
c'est inspire la ou l'une d'entre vous
ça a l'air bien c'est assez
spectaculaire aimé goûter vous savez
dans ces cas là on va revenir à notre
sujet précédent j'avais j'avais j'avais
un peu coupé le sifflet à notre ministre
de la transition écologique nicolas
hulot qui avait j'ai trouvé une
réflexion intéressante et là on en vient
au sujet d'avon puisque si vous voulez
pas parler de foot
ici les invités sont libres sur en fait
la financiarisation de l'économie
laurent bouvet en parlait à l'instant
qu'il regrette
en tenant des propos presque presque
philosophique écouter notre ministre le
rôle d'une entreprise ça ne l'est pas
comme c'est dans le
deux civils aujourd'hui le profit ou en
tout cas l'objet n'était pas le profit
c'était bien de participer à
l'épanouissement humain c'était bien au
service de l'homme il faut revenir aux
fondamentaux parce que si on veut un
siècle pacifié effectivement l'économie
est un moyen au service de l'homme et ça
n'est pas l'homme qui est un moyen au
service de l'économie qui est elle même
est indexé au service de la finance
alors inattendu rêveur notre ministre
n'ont pas tout à fait puisqu'il ya un
débat extrêmement sérieux au sein du
gouvernement mais concerne le contenu de
la prochaine loi le maire ce sera bruno
le maire qu'il apportera presse noah sur
l'économie qui doit éventuellement
redéfinir le quel est le rôle de
l'entreprise bat actuellement le rôle
aux entreprises définies par le code
civil article ni 668 croit dit qu'en
fait c'est fait pour les associés sont
là pour faire du profit
grosso modo et cd voilà ce qu'on a
toujours été habitué à ça et l'idée
c'est de diaba non c'est aussi là pour
le faire le bonheur éventuellement fait
cela c'est moi qui rêve des salariés des
sous traitants de la société tout
entière est donc ce débat n'est pas
tranché parce que pour le moment on sait
que le président la république avait
essayé de le faire entrer ce débat dans
la loi ma points en 2014 2015
il n'avait pas réussi juridiquement
c'est très compliqué et c'est pas sûr
que les équilibres internes du
gouvernement
il satisfait voilà merci beaucoup à tous
les cartes j'espère que vous avez fait
le bonheur des internautes mais je n'en
doute pas au cours de cette émission
ce week-end vous savez qu'il ya des
élections importantes dans la
collectivité unique est devenue la corse
ça sera décrypté dès lundi matin sur
figaro live dans une émission spéciale
des décrypteurs consacré à ce sujet et
d'ici là très bon week-end merci à tous
[Musique]